on Friday president from struggling to
work with Senate Republicans to pass
Obamacare reform suggested a possible
solution maybe just maybe Republicans
should repeal Obamacare and then replace
it piecemeal he tweeted quote if
Republican senators are unable to pass
what they are working on now they should
immediately repeal and then replace at a
later date
naturally conservatives like some people
in this room have been promoting this
policy since literally before the 2016
campaign for like seven years and Trump
and Republicans refused to follow that
policy prescription because they believe
the simple repeal wouldn't be a good
campaign slogan they won't at the cop
out of being able to tell Americans they
had a super double secret plan to
replace Obamacare it turns out there was
no such plan and that the Republican
caucus is fractious and bickering and
that unites big spending moderates with
conservative free marketers and that
it's kind of difficult to replace
Obamacare much more so than to repeal it
outright but only now after months of
talk about how Republicans want to
destroy Medicaid and throw poor people
off cliffs and stab Graham on the chest
this Trump comes to this eminently
obvious solution one of the great
ironies of course is that Trump says
this directly after meeting with Senator
Rand Paul you'll recall the Tennant
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell actually
wanted to first repeal Obamacare
wholesale and then replace it but it was
a guy named Rand Paul who told them not
to do so and told Trump that to do so
would be a mistake now Paul has sweat
between a quote I've spoken to President
Trump in Senate leadership about this
and agree let's keep our word repeal
then work on replacing right away this
follows hard on pressure from
conservative senators Tom cotton and Ben
Sasse who said they would push to
separate repeal in a place into two
pieces well better late than never but
Republicans are running out of time
they made a promise to the American
people no it's time to keep that promise
and it looks like maybe president Trump
is finally on board I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
oh my gosh there's so much going on in
the world and so much of it it's caused
by silliness on Twitter and MSNBC the
big story of the day of course is that
over on MSNBC Mika Brzezinski and Joe
Scarborough are in it with President
Trump and they're in it because
yesterday Mika Brzezinski attacked Trump
on the air and here is what she had to
say about Trump is clip three wait
covers of Time magazine he was so needy
he had not been on time yet that he made
his own okay oh my didn't is your boss
this is your boss he put this on display
it at least five of his clubs it was
first slide by a reporter notice the
you've been sitting on a human TV
exclamation points on the headline
something Time magazine doesn't do the
make-believe cover is dated March 1st
2009 and highlights Trump's reality show
The Apprentice Time magazine has since
asked Trump to remove the phony cover
phony a phony fake pathetic made-up
cover of Time magazine you know that's
your boss in an email to the post White
House couldn't comment on whether the
president knew it was a real cover in
case she called needy and then she
talked about his tiny hands and all this
kind of stuff and so Trump fired back
yesterday with that tweet about how he
could had a bloody facelift and wanted
to meet with him and he said no I won't
meet with her her face is all bloody
it's a weird bloody face face lift face
lift bloody okay so Trump obviously
liked it come on what it is just what is
going on what is going on what what what
alternative universe did we stumble into
every night I go to bed and I think the
world can't get any stupider and then
every morning I wake up and I think well
things were so much smarter last night I
mean this is so dumb and then it got
Dumber so Trump did this routine
yesterday where he tweets out about her
bloody Facebook so he's the President of
the United States for God's sake men
grow a second layer of skin for the love
of God get a shell because this is
ridiculous
I mean if the worst that happens to as
Mika Brzezinski says something unkind
about the size of your hands on national
TV get the hell over it and Mika
Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough I mean
yes they're there they're TV clowns I
mean why is this any surprise so fun so
this morning this comes a very serious
issue
very very serious issues we must take it
super seriously we can't laugh about it
it's very serious
the president is a sexist it's worse
than it's worse than Watergate it's
worse than it's worse than Bill Clinton
stuffing an intern in the Oval Office it
is worse than then then FDR locking up
all Japanese folks in internment camps
it is worse than all of those things
combined the president said about Mika
Brzezinski bloody face so listen do I
think it's appropriate now so I think
that it's degrading to the country yes I
think it's degrading to the office of
the presidency yes but I think we've
been degraded for a while I think Trump
is the culmination of a grand pattern
toward the degradation of our civil
society in any case everybody in the
media just goes insane so Mika and Joe
who are now married I guess they decide
that they are going to skip their
vacation and show back up this morning
because after all as I said yesterday
the only people who benefit in this
Trump Mika Brzezinski Joe Scarborough
battle are the people who I just spoke
about right and I guess us because it's
amusing but aside from that the only
people who benefit are the media who
like to cover this and Trump who likes
to hit the media for his own side to go
yeah yeah okay so in any case they come
out this morning and they say that the
president is is terrible and awful and
then they tell a story okay and this
story is now making the rounds because
they make a relatively serious
accusation about the President of the
United States using the power of his
office to attempt to push them to change
their coverage of him by essentially
blackmailing them here's the story that
they tell we got a call that hey the
National Enquirer is going to run a
negative story against you guys and it
was you know Donald is friends with the
president's friends with the guy that
runs the National Enquirer
and they said if you call the president
up and you apologize for your coverage
then he will pick up the phone and
basically spike the story I had well I
will just say three people at the very
top of the administration calling me and
the response was like are you kidding me
I don't know what they have run a story
I'm not going to do it
the calls kept coming and kept coming
and they were like call you need to call
please call come on Joe just pick up the
phone and calling that's blackmail and
let me explain what they were
threatening I'm they were calling my
children they were calling close friends
I'm at the National Enquirer and they
were pinning the story on my ex-husband
who would absolutely never do that so I
knew immediately it was lie and that
they had nothing and these calls
persisted for quite some time and then
Joe had the conversations that he had
with the White House where they said oh
this could go away okay so there's a
pretty heavy accusation that they're
making right now right they're accusing
the President of the United States and
his top aides of threatening them with a
bad National Enquirer story unless they
unless they apologize to the President
of the United States for being mean to
him now is the story of plausible sure
the story is plausible I mean why
wouldn't it be plausible really I mean
the President of the United States when
he was just candidate Trump was very
very close to the National Enquirer
talked about how to win a Pulitzer
repeated their headlines about Rafael
Cruz murdering JFK and all this nonsense
and then said oh well I didn't have
anything to do with that I have nothing
to do with it okay
I didn't believe it then I don't believe
now that he has no relationship with the
National Enquirer but the National
Enquirer of course denied all of this
The Daily Beast is reporting that Jared
Kushner is one of the people who called
up Joe Scarborough and urged him to to
apologize to President Trump
okay but here is the bigger question
okay this actually is a bigger question
because Trump using you know being a
blunt instrument of self-destruction is
not anything remotely shocking right if
he actually did this and we isn't if
because Scarborough and Mika are
alleging this and and he's saying he has
text to prove it I assume that will see
those texts sometime in the near future
Trump is saying but that's not what
happened that actually Scarborough
called Trump and urged him to kill the
National Enquirer story
Scarborough says I have phone records
showing that the calls went the other
way okay whatever all of this is not
shocking in any real way because all of
the actors are acting just as you would
expect them to act me and president
Trump is not only a bull in a china shop
he threatens people he does I mean this
is not like a big shock it's not and
it's a bad thing it's a bad thing but I
have another question and this is one
more about the media
why didn't mica and Joe meek and Joe
reveal this when it happened so they
said that they told NBC News higher-ups
this happened apparently in April early
May
it is now last I checked late June what
happened in the last few months why
didn't they reveal this at the time
pretty devastating accusation right I
mean if at the time you come at me say
this morning I got a call from the White
House there's a National Enquirer story
that's about to run into hit piece on me
and mica and the President of the United
States called me up and said he wanted a
personal apology from me or the National
Enquirer was going to run the story you
don't think that's newsworthy you don't
think that's newsworthy why wouldn't you
reveal that and this demonstrates the
point that I'm making this demonstrates
the tacit game that is being played by
the media and by Trump by the White
House and by the media and it was true
during Obama it's true now there's a
tacit game that's being played to raise
everybody's ratings and to keep
attention on the media and and the last
thing they want to do is destroy the
game what we are watching right now is a
giant Kabuki theater well we are
watching right now is WWE if this were
legit fight Joe Scarborough and Miko to
come out immediately and reveal this
story if somebody if the White House
threatened me with coverage do you think
I would hold that back or do you think I
would report that I would report that
today of right the day of before the
phone call was over I would be texting
other media Alice Mayer you crazy
why wouldn't I report that that is the
most newsworthy thing we can Joe have
ever done a lot more news word is that a
coverage of Trump but you can see the
Kabuki theater because now they have to
come back and try and claim the
dissolved giant shock to them right they
have to claim it it's all just a big
surprise to them so here are Mackenzie
Oh
this morning saying well you know we
never expected this from President Trump
really knows how fake knows you never
expected this from never expected this
from Donald J Trump the most public
figure in probably American history
Donald that guy you want to tennis for
firing people and bullying people and
being a general jackass you never
expected this kind of behavior from like
after last year when he insulted Heidi
Cruz's looks via Twitter after last year
when he said that Carly eh Carly
fiorina's face was reason enough to vote
for her but really that's the fake news
big news that Trump will trump change
company again all excuse making because
this is all just a game it's all just
again here they are the guy that's in
the White House now is not the guy we
knew two years ago I'll attend the White
House now is not even close because the
Donald Trump we knew for the better
part of 1012 years was always in on the
joke yeah he like he go here's some
water and then of the week at yeah right
here's this look at it and it always
went can I do on that yeah yeah luckily
today like that you know I do like they
just come here they love seeing my name
it makes them feel like they're part is
something he was always in on the joke
without getting into great detail I will
just say that somebody at the top of his
campaign last summer said to me we're
all really worried about his emotional
state yeah but this is our name we
change now this is an are no said I'm
telling nobody said yeah this guy is not
even the same person he was not here
okay
he's totally radically changed are you
out of your mind he's totally radically
changed really really really come on no
what what is all this a what it really
says is again there's a game being
played where the media have an interest
in playing up the drama and Trump has an
interest in playing up the drama and a
lot of the drama is overwrought and
think because doesn't mean things about
Trump says mean things about make all of
it is wildly inappropriate from the
office of the presidency it's
inappropriate for the media to to attack
the president's teeny hands for no
reason it's just vindictive and stupid
and all of it is just a monster of the
fact that after all this is over I
promise you within three months mica and
Joe will be at the White House hanging
out with Trump and doing an interview
where they're all making love okay
that's that's what's going to happen I
promise within the next few months all
of this will blown over and Trump will
do an apology to them and it'll be a
quality of how to not apologize to him
and Elmo I'll make up and it'll be all
sweet a night at least on the surface
okay maybe down deep they hate each
other but it's all just it's all just
stupid stuff and Trump is not helping
himself with it and the media are not
helping themselves they're helping
themselves in the writing but they are
not helping themselves when it comes to
their credibility their credibility
continues to fail now speaking of their
failing credibility you know Trump
continues to attack CNN so well he's now
attacking MSNBC he's also attacking CNN
so he's going after CNN he has been for
a couple weeks yesterday who's speaking
its energy week lest you lest you forget
it is energy week I like when they
declare it a particular week and then
the week has nothing to do with what
they said it was going to be about
energy week is apparently bloody
facelift week and all of American
politics I think at this point we can
all agree
bloody facelift a bloody bloody facelift
okay so here is president from talking
about CNN and it's fake news many of us
remember the long gas lines and a
constant claims that the world was
running out of oil and natural gas
Americans were told that our nation
could only solve this energy crisis by
imposing draconian restrictions on
energy production but we now know that
was all a big beautiful myth it was fake
don't we love that term fake what we've
learned about fake over the last little
while fake news CN n fake okay so this
is like a little Pavlovian response
another smile wink at the camera okay
again this is being broadcast on CNN the
whole game is pretty transparent but you
know the what's even more transparent is
that none of this has to do with
bettering our politics in in any serious
way so James O'Keefe has been doing a
really interesting series of videos
where he went sort of undercover with
CNN and he's got a bunch of CNN people
on tape saying things now here's the
stuffs I think that that O'Keefe is
covering that is worthwhile and here's
the stuff I think that is just the link
and not at the conservative audience ooh
here is some read me eat it right okay
so the stuff that matters is the first
producer who talked to this job on a
field guide said openly at the top of
the network was saying to cover the rush
of stuff even though there was no
substance to it for ratings that is a
substance of critique of CNN that is an
important thing that right there is
breaking news from James O'Keefe that
actually matters right that's the stuff
that I care about which is CNN actually
like what we see on TV is a lie and
they're doing it for ratings that's
actual news what is not actual news is
the various random thoughts in private
of random associate producer so O'Keefe
broke another tape last night in which
he caught an associate producer of CNN
on tape saying some nasty things about
the American voter and about Kellyanne
Conway and here is what it looked like
in it it's an impartial right that I had
what's the view of Trump in like fun of
media sir
on the inside we all recognize is that
music hilariously unfunny qualifies
really basses and it does not have any
resonances we recognize Jeff claims his
look years ago this is many on that
Republican because about 48 minutes
he doesn't believe anything lands on a
dirt bike
I guarantee you he's my first or she
doesn't care about gay marriage he
doesn't even really care about the
budget right a man's offend alleged even
be promised to arrange it you may need
to be totally gay mother joke yeah
I don't think 90% of its Ron or just
with just attract what you mean 90% a
whole lot is like I would with her I
wouldn't say with her but just
acknowledge detected Jean Louis better
get away okay so this part right here
with savage there for a second so when
he says when he says all the stuff this
is the newsworthy stuff where he says
everybody at CNN agrees that Trump is
crazy okay that's newsworthy because now
he's talking about the entirety of CNN
he's talking about how everyone at CNN
who pretends to be objective is actually
not objective they think that Trump is
crazy okay
all of that is newsworthy and all of
that is true I mean it's not not that
Trump is crazy but that they think this
we all knew this right is that any great
shock to many of us no it's not a shock
that people CNN think this in fact some
of them come out and say it openly on
air while purporting to be objective so
that's not a shock the part that I
object to about this tape a little bit
is the part that's coming up and that is
this associate producer then starts
giving his private views about about
various matters sundry and I think that
we're stepping into a little bit of
dangerous territory here and I'll
explain why but before I do that I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. CCA so we're living in a world
that feels increasingly dangerous it
feels like there are there's more
violence there there was an uptick in
murder in the last couple of years in
major cities around the United States if
you are concerned not only about the
possibility of violence the possibility
of things like home invasion about
robberies and carjackings well then you
should probably own a gun and you should
know how
use it and you Seca makes sure that you
can do both and they also make sure that
if God forbid you have to use your gun
in a self-defense situation they have
all the legal necessities that you are
going to need because it's not quite as
easy as the cops show up say it's
self-defense and leave you can
definitely be caught up in a criminal
justice system even when you do the
right thing with the gun so what the
u.s. CCA does what the u.s.
concealed-carry Association does when
they give responsible gun owners like
you and me complete peace of mind in an
unpredictable world by educating us
training us making sure we are legally
and financially protected for after we
pull the trigger and they also help us
get armed so right now in honor of 4th
of July they are doing the great
American giveaway this is awesome they
want my listeners to know about it ok
great American giveaway by July 4th if
you win if you win you go over to their
site defend my family now calm you get
five chances to win defend my family now
to come yet five chances to win 1776
dollars for the guns and ammo of your
choice like 1776 so you've got a ton of
money for the guns and ammo of your
choice when you go and you can register
to win defend my family now calm and get
five chances to win as a free shot at
1776 dollars worth of guns and ammo you
should register with defend my family
now calm anyway because you get all
those other resources I talked about the
educational resources the financial
resources the legal resource Galit stuff
with you Seca but you also get the cool
opportunity to win 1776 dollars worth of
guns and ammo at defend my family now
calm and you can register for five
chances to win make sure that you check
them out we appreciate it okay so on to
the rest of this interview one of the
things that I've seen from the right and
this is happening in defense of Trump is
this attempt to say that when Trump
tweets nasty things out about Mika
Brzezinski
that this is the equivalent of what
you're about to see from an associate
CNN producer saying something privately
so I'm going to play the clip and then
I'll explain why I think that trying to
cover this is news is mistaken and
foolish and and pretty silly to me I
don't want to be rude here the only some
percentage small scholarship but if
that's a question an employee may have
consulta another student now then it
quickly it happened right on White House
we actually had that Ottoman galleon
common you know lawn Kirlian right
what'd she look like the is she doing
reserve ammunition okay so the people on
the right are saying well you know
you've got this associate producer Jimmy
Carter of CNN saying that she looks like
she got hit with a shovel first of all
there are a thousand associate producers
at CNN but you know people are saying oh
look at this this is just as bad as
Trump it's just terrible it's just the
worst thing and it's just as bad as
Trump's the same right that is excused
Trump on the bloody faceless stuff and
on the Fiorina space stuff and the hi
Cruz ugly stuff they say this associate
producer at CNN how dare he how dare he
and here is my problem with this and
even though he sense about the American
voter okay
like I I've said I think on the show
before that I think a lot of voters are
dumb okay we voted for Obama twice
okay the American public voted for Obama
twice and then gave us as nominees
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump I'm not
going to go with the all-knowing wisdom
of the American voter I think that we
are wise about our own interests I'm not
sure that we are wise about politics or
the Constitution which is why the
country has been consistently drifting
left for the last 80 years but you know
everybody oh my god he said the voters
are stupid okay come on come on you've
said the voters are stupid be real you
said it you said look at all these other
people they're so dumb okay come on
everybody has said that and then this
guy says that Kelly uncommon looks like
she got hit with a shovel so is this
something he should have said no it's
not something you should have said but
I'm getting concerned about the tendency
both right and left to suggest that
private speech is exactly the same as
public speech that if you say something
privately to your friend that's exactly
the same as the President of the United
States the most powerful man on planet
earth going on Twitter and saying it no
no okay there are only three types of
people who say exactly the same thing in
public that they say in private
okay Saints because they say great
things wonderful things in private and
they say wonderful things in public okay
evil people who say evil things in
private and then they don't care that
they're evil and so they say evil things
publicly and fools right who will just
say whatever comes to mind and doesn't
matter if they're public does matter if
they're private they're exactly the same
in public is in private the rest of us
we say things to our friends that we
don't want publicly exposed we say
things to our spouses we don't want
publicly exposed one of the aspects of
freedom one of the basic aspects of
freedom is this distinction between
public and private
we used to recognize this totalitarian
country basically said there should be
no distinction what you say in public
and what you say in private should be
exactly the same so we will tape you
will put the Stasi on you will make sure
that you never say anything privately
because maybe maybe you're thinking that
when you go out neck publicly in a free
society how we treat each other publicly
is how we judge one another so if I
think privately god I really don't feel
like giving charity but then I sign a
hundred dollar check to a charity my
private thoughts are of no consequence
to the society around me okay only my
actions only my actions or if I say
privately to somebody god I really
really can't stand that Barack Obama
he's just awful then I go out publicly
and I say you know he's not my favorite
president I don't like his policies is
that the end of the world no it's not
the end of the world okay and this whole
idea that we're supposed to invade
everybody's proud like especially people
who were pro trunk I think it was pretty
consistent on this I said this about
Donald sterling who is I think a
complete douchebag but Donald sterling
was caught on tape by his
then-girlfriend V stiviano saying that
he didn't want Magic Johnson coming to
Lakers games because he is black or
something and I and then he walked the
entire Clippers team and I said he
didn't want them going Clippers games
and I said I think that he's a horrific
person but I don't like the idea that we
are going to deprive people of their
careers and resources based on private
conversations that they have because we
all say things to each other privately
that we don't want expose publicly and
if you disagree with me then I suggest
you take all of your emails and you dump
them publicly
I suggest you tape all of your private
conversations and dump them publicly the
distinction between private and public
is very important because you practice
out in private what it is appropriate to
say in public so yes it matters more it
matters more that the president tweets
nasty things out than it does the Jimmy
Carr a CNN Associate Producer said in a
private conversation at a coffee house
that Kellyanne Conway looks like she was
hit in the face of the shovel yes it
matters more because the president is
the president and this guy's a random
dude and second because the president
deliberately said it publicly I
guarantee if you put Jimmy Carr on
camera publicly you put him on CNN and
asked him what do you think of Kelly on
Conway's looks you wouldn't say anything
like this we all say things privately
that we wouldn't say publicly because we
know that it is not appropriate to say
things publicly and that's a good thing
that's not a lack of honesty that's what
allows us to live with each other if we
said all the things publicly that we
said about
privately we would never be able to live
with each other okay this is called tact
this is why some of us have it okay it's
a useful thing and undermining that on
behalf of a guy who just says whatever
comes to mind
final thing from is evil I just think
that he's a fool when it comes to him
saying private thoughts publicly you
know that I don't mean is the same as
some of his followers seem to think and
I don't think that he's evil as some of
his detractors seem to think I think
that he's foolish about how he uses his
his rhetoric and language you know just
because he does that doesn't mean that
we should undermine this difference
between private and public we practice
in private what we say in public and yes
we should be better about what we say in
private too but that is not the same
thing as what we say in public and if we
make these the same thing we are going
to destroy a civil society in which we
all can live okay so as we continue here
on the show we are going to talk about
the mailbag and we are going to talk
about the Democrats of course losing
their minds over all of this and totally
hypocritical ridiculous fashion because
they are going over the top on all of
this and it's really stupid but for that
you're going to have to subscribe so for
$8 a month you can get a subscription to
daily wire.com you get the rest of this
show live you get the mailbag get to be
part of the live mailbag which we are
doing today and if you get an annual
subscription you get a signed copy of
say it so book about baseball and
fathers and sons that I wrote with my
pops it's a really good book and you get
a free signed copy when you get an
annual subscription also make sure that
you get your subscription now if you
wait till July 10th our rates are going
up get your subscription now lock it in
and then you're going to keep that low
rate locked in which is what you want
and and if you want to listen later on
iTunes or SoundCloud make sure that you
go over there and subscribe and leave us
a review we always appreciate it we will
be back here at the 9 a.m. live on
Facebook
and and if you want to listen the show
later obviously use any of the
methodologies that we have already
talked about and we will see you on the
other side
you